okay let's jump into audience questions
for the week first question about guns
david why have mass shootings
skyrocketed in the united states it is
true that mass shootings have increased
in the united states
um there is unlikely to be
a significant agreement on this issue
politically right now
but to me it seems very clear that there
are at least a few factors that together
have led the united states to be in the
situation that it's in now
for the people that focus only on guns
i actually don't think guns are the
problem they are a major problem in the
united states the easy availability of
firearms
combined with the lack of a universal
background check program
the lack of an insurance requirement uh
the
uh ease with which you can purchase uh
large capacity magazines i mean
there's a lot that relates to guns but
there are countries like switzerland and
i know it's almost cliche to even bring
it up at this point in time
there are countries with high rates of
gun ownership that do not have
our gun violence problem and that is
because of something else and i believe
that it is a result of
culture and by culture i mean gun
culture in the united states
the idea that in the united states more
than in
so many other of the rich oecd countries
in the united states there's this idea
where people see firearms
as a solution to problems as a solution
to interpersonal problems
as a solution to being an incel i mean i
know it sounds weird but like
that that's also a factor in some of
these shootings in individual cases
it's a solution to work problems it's a
solution to political problems in the
eyes of many
that is very different than in other
countries and so
when you look at things like should we
have universal background checks well
yeah of course
when you look at the 2004 uh the the
federal assault weapons ban
which expired in 2004. there were there
was a spike
in shootings uh after that expired
but there is a debate as to the degree
to which it is responsible because there
was also
um the the sort of uh furthering of this
wacky right-wing
gun culture at that point in time during
the era of george w
bush and so it seems clear
that there is a unique set of
circumstances in the united states which
is
culture which includes ignorant people
it includes um uh people who see guns as
a solution the problems
availability of guns yes and then also
you know lack of access to mental health
care
and the fact that even for people who do
have access it's often highly
stigmatized extremism there is a lot of
extremism in the united states
compared to many other countries which
leads people to look for
things like guns with which to then then
go and do things
so my point here is not to say
uh that is that that it is one issue at
the
exclusion of others or that we shouldn't
be looking deeply at gun safety
itself we absolutely should but we need
to understand
that there is also something special in
the united states
a lot of these movements that in other
countries are
hyper fringe like hyper hyper fringe
in the united states they are fringe but
it's a big enough country where there's
still a lot of them
60 minutes um segment over last weekend
about
the oath keepers which um is one of
these right-wing
militia type groups these things exist i
get it there's this
right nationalist front in many uh
european countries and you know
australia has examples of these groups
australia has a very different gun law i
think it's important to say but there is
a huge cultural component which if we
ignore
we need to focus on the gun piece
because we're humiliatingly behind on
dealing with guns
but there's also something special and i
don't mean in a good way
about american culture that correlates
uh and
and i believe is causally related to
these shootings as well
one of our sponsors today is nebia the
creator of the world's most
innovative shower head it uses only
about
half the water that other shower heads
do saving you money helping the
environment
but it's actually a lot more powerful
than other shower heads on the market it
has twice the coverage of other shower
heads
the water sprays with a ton of pressure
i've been using it in my bathroom at
home i love it
only took a few minutes to set up really
easy and it's been a totally different
experience
than any other shower head i've used i
can get in and out of the shower way
quicker now
because of how powerful it is it only
takes a few seconds to get completely
rinsed off
so i was actually amazed that it's only
using about half as much
water nebia also offers a number of
shower accessories like shelves and
curtains which match
perfectly with the design of the shower
head the shower head starts at just 199
but the first hundred people who go to
nebia.com
pacman and use code pacman will get
15 off all nebia products the link is
underneath this video